If you have been following along with this
series of tutorials, you may have noticed
that there is no Undo within Chimera, other than
the Undo Selection feature. In this final video,
we will explore three workarounds for this
issue, using the hemoglobin structure 4hhb.
We can use the command line to save a
structure's position in the graphics window.
Let's say you are ready to begin exploring this
structure but don't want to lose the current view.
The solution is to type into the command line
"savepos p1" and press Enter. This command defines
the current position as "position 1" in Chimera's
memory. Now you can safely explore the structure
in the graphics window. To return to the original
position, all you need to do is enter into the
command line "reset p1". You can extend this basic
technique to save more than one position — just
label your second position as "p2", your third
as "p3", and so on as you define more positions.
Following the "savepos" command, you can also
type names that are more specific than the
p+integer naming system that I just demonstrated.
In fact, you can type whatever name you want.
For example, we could save this position
using the command "savepos heme" since we
are focusing in on a particular heme group.
The reset format is the same as before — we
just enter into the command line "reset
heme" to recover the initial position.
For this workaround, it is key that you are
working within a session file that has previously
been saved using Save As. Chimera's file directory
makes it easy to identify such files. In this
list, files marked with an extension have been
saved beforehand, while those without an extension
have not. With that knowledge, let's open the
hemoglobin structure we have been looking at.
The idea behind this workaround is to save the
session as you modify the structure. Let's say
we go to Actions, Ribbon, and turn on
Ribbon Edging; now we can go to File
and save the change. Then we decide to select the
heme groups and change their depiction to Sphere.
But at this point, you realize that you like the
heme groups better in their original depiction.
So rather than saving this change, the next
step is to close the session. Upon reopening it,
the heme groups are restored, but the ribbon
edging remains because we had previously saved
that change. In this way, we can effectively
create an artificial Undo within Chimera.
Finally, we can use Chimera's animation interface
to store structure depiction modifications. Before
making any changes, let's start by taking a
snapshot of the structure in its default state.
Now we go to Actions, Color, All Options, and
selectively color the ribbons cyan. Then we stop
and take a snapshot of the result. For our next
change, we will select the heme groups and color
them red. We then take another snapshot of the
result. Next we select chain A, edge its ribbons,
and snapshot the result. Now we have created
a history of our depiction changes within the
animation interface. By left-clicking on
the snapshots, we can easily recover past
states of the structure and access any
of the depictions created along the way.